In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadion, for May 27th, on which we commemorate our righteous
and God-bearing Father, John the Russian, Confessor and Wonderworker.
On the 27th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father, John the Russian,
Confessor and Wonderworker.
Our Holy Father, John, was born in a village in Little Russia, and grew up in Piety and
love for the Holy Virtues.
Reaching adulthood at the time of the Russo-Turkish War in 1710, he enrolled in the Tsar's
Army, captured by the Tatters, he was sold to a Turkish cavalry officer who took him home
to Prokopion in Cappadocia.
Like many of his companions in captivity who abjured Christianity, St. John resisted
both the suggestions and blows of his master, saying that no suffering could separate him from
the love of Christ.
He added,
You are the master of my body, but not of my soul.
If you leave me free to carry out my religious obligations, I will obey your orders with
alacrity.
It is a pleasure to me to sleep in this corner of your stable, thinking of Christ who considered
the manger in Bethlehem to be a royal bed.
I will endure without complaint your blows as the Lord endured those of the soldiers.
I am ready to endure the greatest and most terrible torments if you want to submit me
to them, but I shall never deny Christ.
These words, so full of Christian fervor, along with his chaste and humble behavior,
completely changed the heart and feelings of the Turkish officer towards him.
He stopped tyrannizing over him and did not require him to deny his faith.
Given the task of looking after the horses, John lived in a dark corner of the stable, and
when his master rode out into the village, he had to follow him on foot like a slave.
The blessed man, however, accepted this degrading state with gratitude and glorified God
for having thus delivered him from apostasy.
Barefoot, summer and winter, clad in rags and taking snatches of rest on the straw or the
dunghill like righteous Job, John did not in any way obeyed his exercises of devotion, and
he spent whole nights in prayer kneeling on the forecourt of the neighboring church of Saint
George.
He accepted without murmur the insults and mockery of the other slaves, and willingly
put himself at their service.
These sacrifices and striving in virtue were not without beneficial effects for his master,
who became the richest and most respected man in his town.
Having decided to make a pilgrimage to Mecca, obligatory for all devout Muslims, he reached
the holy city after a long, difficult journey.
Several weeks after his departure, his wife invited their kinsfolk and friends to a great
dinner so that the guests could express their hopes for her husband's safe return.
When John went into the room to serve a large pilaf, the mistress in the house exclaimed,
how its master would rejoice if he were here to eat this dish with us while it is so appetizing.
John with Drew a few moments in silent prayer, and then asked his mistress to give him a full
dish of the pilaf to send to his master in Mecca.
While all the guests were mocking him, the mistress of the house, smilingly, gave him a dish
of the rice.
John went to the stable and raised the following prayer to God.
May he, who in former times, sent the prophet Habakkuk to Babylon to carry food to the prophet
Daniel in the lion's den, give ear also to my prayer and bring this dish to my master.
He then returned to the banqueting hall and announced that the dish had arrived at its destination.
Everyone present burst out laughing and accused him of being secretly fooled to replicion.
However, when the master returned from his journey, bringing with him the empty dish bearing
his initials and told how he had found it full of a delicious pilaf one evening when
he returned to his tent, everyone in the house was stupified, and invoking Allah began to
accord honor and great respect to the Christian slave.
They offered to give him his freedom and a more worthy chamber, but St. John refused, saying
that he preferred to remain in the dark corner of the stable where he could better glorify
God.
He thus lived a devout life for several years.
When he fell ill, he asked that a priest bring him holy communion, but the priest, afraid
to take the sacrament into a Muslim house, hid it in an apple and gave it to the saint.
Thus St. John received the viaticum of eternal life and fell asleep in peace to obtain the
glorious liberty of the children of God on the 27th of May in 1730.
Three years later, an elderly priest and some other Christians several times saw at night
a pillar of fire that descended from heaven onto the saint's tomb.
They opened it and found their his incorrupt body, giving off a sweet fragrance.
They then took it with great rejoicing to the Church of St. George and placed it in
a reliquary under the altar.
From then on the precious relics worked the great number of miracles for the Christians of
Cappadocia and even for the Muslims.
During the sacking of the village by the troops of Osman Pasha, the relics were burned by the
Turkish soldiers, but they remained untouched, and the saint appeared in the midst of the
flames, threatening the infidel soldiers.
The terrified Turks abandoned all their spoils and fled from the village.
On another occasion, the saint appeared to hold up with his own hands the roof of the
Greek school that was collapsing, thus saving the 20 children who were inside.
At the time of the expulsion of the Greeks from Asia Minor in 1922, the Christians of Procopion
took these holy relics with them to Greece.
To the village of Neoprocopion on the island of Elbea as their greatest treasure.
St. John has, since then, been venerated as a limitless source of healing and blessing
by all who draw near to him with faith.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.